Texas Tech head basketball coach he's
Chris beard joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
he's been i if you do I want to know if
he knows where he's been all the
different coaching stops but he's found
a home here at Texas Tech he was there
as a Bob Knight's associate head coach
of Texas Tech in 2001 and 2008 and he's
got his team in the coach great to see
you glad to be here all right
can you name in order all of the stops
in your coaching career you know I used
to make fun of coaches that couldn't
okay can somebody look and see all of
his coaching stop so we can we can fact
check this but this is what people don't
realize they see you at the Final Four
they don't know where you've been for
the last 15 to 20 years
all right Paul you ready you got the
list we have Wikipedia if there we
believe in him okay how many stops do we
have there just to let coach refreshes
memory of all of his coaching stops I
got 12 okay coach
you ready started at the University of
Texas with Tom fenders okay then we went
to Incarnate Word with Danny Casper okay
and we made a great move to Abilene
Christian with Shannon Hays then we got
our first head coaching job at Fort
Scott Community College hired by ad
Kevin Gundy what what what
North Texas 97 through 99
yeah I've already messed it up okay yeah
you've had a lot of stuff sorry Victor
Lee thank you for that job Forge gun
okay no more chance yeah after Incarnate
Word we went to Abilene Christian
correct Shannon Hayes then we went to
dividual in first division one job
University of North Texas in Denton work
for Victor Lee sorry coach
then we got our first head coaching job
Fort Scott Community College Kansas
Kevin Gundy hired his there coach Gundy
he'll be at the game Saturday oh nice
really looking forward to seeing him
more than coach izzo defense next head
coach and job was Seminole State College
in Oklahoma hired by rusty beam then I
had the chance of a lifetime got hooked
up a coach night and Pat had a great
rant run in Lubbock and that's where it
gets a little a little complicated here
after Lubbock went to South Carolina and
coached the Warriors the ABA South
Carolina Warriors I went even aware that
there was a team there we did have the
corndog deal if you scored a hundred
points like Will Ferrell and semi-pro
okay four more stops after South
Carolina warriors we went to McMurry
University in Abilene hired by coach Ron
Holmes then we went to Angelo State
hired by dr. may and ad Shawn Johnson I
got a first division one chance the only
with the little rock chaise-cart gave us
an opportunity we took a small trip to
Las Vegas and then we ended up at Texas
Tech I'm proud to be a tech hell how to
do all correct did well and we're all
out of time Chris so thank you for
joining us we appreciate it enjoy the
Final Four I like that you you blew out
your ACL that was during again right
actually no you know what against Iowa
State it's even more embarrassing than
that I I blew it out the night before
the game and practice Dyer Smith is in
the NBA now we're gonna set a flare
screen from the corner so I showed him
how to do it for it my knee we wrapped
it up really good that day and Ames I
told coach prohm don't tell anybody but
I'll probably have a really quick
handshake with you cuz I can't walk
within the flow of the game 9:00
Stephenson and I had a little bit
different opinion on what we should do
on a key offensive possession
I forgot that my knee was tore up and
that's when I fell down so most people
think that I taught in a game but
actually toward the night before but you
said that you wanted to finish the game
you didn't want them those those fans to
think you were soft yes I've always
loved Iowa State fans they had the best
postgame meal at all college basketball
wait what are you two wings and a warm
roast beef sandwich right after the game
win or lose yes oh so I've always loved
Iowa State but their basketball people
you know they'll cheer for your team
even if they're rooting against you but
I have even more respect for him now
because literally nobody made fun of me
even though I fell down
on my face in the middle of a Division
one national television game I love Iowa
State people so were you good at
basketball in my own mind I was because
we had Bruce Pearl in and he barely
played he said I football in baseball
yeah I was a five year redshirt at the
University of Texas for Tom Pittman
coach was great coach punishment some
time with us last week at the regional
in Anaheim and I think I don't know if
he's just getting a lot nicer or maybe
his memories starting to go the other
way but he's got me scoring like eight
points a game I senior I just remember
sitting behind the bench you know not
giving him a pointer from time to time
but how do you teach if you haven't
played you haven't experienced that yeah
well he was a lot of us to play we just
maybe didn't play at the highest level
you know in nobody loves basketball more
than me and so I was a big part of my
childhood growing up I just wasn't a
Division one player and I knew early on
that I wanted to coach and so I got a
great opportunity but coach Pender's how
do you stay married with all these
stumps I'm not married I didn't yeah
over 100 men oh you did no for one but
you have three daughters three daughters
and a beautiful boyfriend now Randy so
I'm gonna try to do a little bit better
here the second time but it's so tough
on families yeah with your travel
recruiting your uprooting I mean that I
think that's some of this that people
don't realize that's a big part is final
four to kind the emotion that goes into
it's not just the games and the players
it's like just thinking of all the
people including your family that gave
you a chance to do this you know I've
been coming to Final Fours for almost 25
years I was the small college guy
sleeping in my car trying to get the
free food from the buffet sitting so
high up top you can't even see the floor
so this this weekend will be great for
so many reasons but just thinking of the
path and then thinking about the
sacrifices my family made you know so
let me get to this points pretty cool
what's just like we're you look over
your shoulder and there it is I mean
you're working Saturday in that building
and you can't play for the national
title it's just awesome I first of all
look like a pirate ship
so I never coached in a pirate ship but
uh no it's everything it's uh you
nervous now I don't get nervous we
talked to our guys a lot this week
simple playing at Texas Tech this is not
high level coaching
we send em along I want to smell the
roses like we don't want to be that team
that comes down says it's a normal trip
it's a bath this is not a normal trip
it's the final four so we've been
enjoying everything but when it's time
to play we want to try to beat us we
want to be the team that got us here the
team that won the big 12 River season
championship so it's that fine line
between smelling the roses and join the
ride but then also trying to play our
best game of the year Saturday you're
also you're known for your defense
that's a great defensive team Virginia's
a great defensive team
Michigan State great defensive team just
defense win championships I think so
you know teams that guarded a high-level
defense can come in different forms but
yeah you have to guard you have to guard
on your end you gotta do it all year so
it's the DNA of our program Mark Adams
on our staffs one of the best guys that
nobody's heard of we had a great
nationally ranked defense at Little Rock
and it's no surprise we have it at Texas
Tech coach root defense like guys
everybody wants to be a scorer everybody
wants to be a star and you know you're
trying to get guys to play defense well
you know I heard your understanding you
didn't pick us with your mission state
game no I did not you know the whole
true telling' atmosphere you know maybe
and recruiting maybe in recruiting we
don't talk about defense but you better
be able to play defense if you come to
Texas yeah we're 20 minutes in the first
practice and we hadn't pulled the balls
out yet Matt Mooney looks at me as I
coach so to Jers your Normandale yeah we
just don't have the preacher son same
prayers and the Wheatfield you get fired
up though yeah no doubt that's who we
are I mean you can't hold back emotions
don't want to not during a game does
anybody your daughters ever sake that oh
yeah he'll they get embarrassed every
game
they're like most people though when we
win they won't be embarrassed if you win
Saturday problem don't we're in problem
yeah it's kind of kind of life what's
what's the worst moment aside from
blowing out your ACL where you look back
or you watch yourself on TV and go and
that's not good effects I'm not a very
good dresser boy I saw coach pearl like
I think I look a little bit better quit
for no offense coach yeah we're both
under armor though okay who was a well
dressed coach Jay Wright last year
yeah J that's not fair what J looks like
Williams always looks the ball classy
damper yeah classy Coach K has been
wearing that same blue blazer I think
for about 30 years right yeah but it
just pops man he's got the the reign of
its big time yeah he's been great by the
way he sent me a tape I'm just a normal
guy man again a couple years ago I was
down here you know drinking draft beer
trying to find a ticket and now you know
Coach K like text me this week so it's
like it's surreal it's what he's saying
it's good luck so we'd played him in due
course he had a great game yeah except
for we kept giving the ball to Duke and
then no he's just been great I think I
think people kind of sometimes see
themselves in our teams because we try
to play the game the right way yeah I
mean we're talking to Chris B or the
Texas Tech head coach joining us here at
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
yeah you're one of those lifers you're
one of those guys that you might not
notice and but then all of a sudden you
notice how his teams play I don't know
what it was that Bob Knight goes I want
you as my associate head coach this is
one of the great coaches of all time how
does that happen where he notices you
and notices something special in you
yeah he's just really fortunate you know
I tell the guys all the time you're
gonna get a couple breaks in life it's
just up to you to recognize them and
take advantage and that was mine there
was like a PhD in coaching every day but
a big piece of my relationship with
coach in my store was Pat Knight that's
the one that endorsed it Pat today's the
one of my best friends so none of this
happens if it's not for Pat and
obviously coach Knight what's your
favorite story coach Knight you know I
was thinking of a go in the other day
people would just write him letters and
call him just for year after year
basketball wise and he you know he he'll
get to it eventually but if anybody just
even wrote him a letter about anything
to do with hunting he would call him Ely
so one day we were we were in the office
and I was when Coach had a reunion Bill
Russell
Havlicek Charlie pride of all different
likes were there supporting coach
because it was his first game coming
back from his year absence between
Indiana and Tech you know and there's a
bunch of people in the room everybody's
talking about man I've been trying to
get ahold of Bob forever I've been
trying to get ahold coach Knight finally
got him this one guy in the middle of
the room just Levi's come a flannel
shirts like that's funny I wrote Bob not
a handwritten letter I didn't know who
he was he called me personally the next
day
in the world kind of stopped what do you
mean is like this guy just had like a
dove a dove lease some land out in West
Texas
and he wrote coach a letter hey if you
ever want to come out and hurt Birds
coach sees the letter picks up the phone
calls that's Bob night you know did he
ever walk in with camo and honor all the
time as a young coach one time we had a
Saturday morning practice six a.m. I
remember thinking what are we doing but
I was this Bob night I'm not questioning
anything you know and so about thirty
minutes into practice it was a really
good practice in my opinion but coach
went crazy on one like closeout kicked
them out you guys don't want to practice
today word done goes crazy we walked
back to the locker room as a young coach
I'm welcome back there thinking man I'm
about to see like a bob night moment in
the locker room coach's comments can be
but he's putting on camo
he's like boy sometimes you gotta shake
the tree I'm going to hunt Turkey today
in Garden City Kansas so so he
orchestrated that so he could go hunting
absolutely now I'll do that it's not
based on hunting but like you know if I
if I'm really hungry and I want an early
dinner
I might just kind of create some
confusion at practice and kick them out
so I'm going really really how would
life change if you win this thing I
really don't think it will I mean I you
know I am Who I am so did UCLA reach out
to you and I'm here to win a game okay
no but I understand I understand you got
you got things but I was curious because
that's a compliment to you but UCLA had
reached out to Calipari and I'd heard
they'd reached out to you as well
me nah not me personally yeah I've got a
cell phone that I answer about once
every three days so there could be a lot
of people reaching out to me that I
don't know about which by the way I'm
sorry everybody out there you know
return next we've got our kind of a rule
in our family or our group of friends is
like you know if you're that guy that
doesn't return clothes then you're
buying the round this summer when we go
to the river but I guys I don't think
this is qualifies me having to buy all
the beer I can't believe that three
years ago your you know drinking draft
beer trying to get a ticket just to go
to the Final Four
like you just want somebody to notice
you and you want to talk basketball what
you know what are you doing no it's just
a great game let's telling people though
they like basketball didn't care of the
game
doesn't care if you're like man how can
I be in this category with Coach Izzo
and this I mean it's because it's the
game yeah it's the love of the game it's
getting a team to go that loves it and
you pay the price and at the end of the
day the sports greater than all of us
and I think that's why guys like me get
a chance
Bruce Pearl cried before you first
emotional guy
when's the last time you cried you don't
strike me as a crier actually had tears
of joy the other day I'd say I know the
same place almost every morning to get
my breakfast burrito yeah and now people
ask me all the time how I stay humble
this is how you know I always order it
and I forget to order the extra salsa
what's the name of the place I mean I
got about three I go to so I really
don't want to go there okay every time
in one place you know I'm talking about
[Laughter]
salsa and then it's 30 cents and you got
to get back in line to pay the 30 so I
get my first Head Division one job you
know I'm at Texas tuck maybe I got a
little bit of an ego but so I'm thinking
hey I get that extra salsa ladies like
yeah 30 cents soy sauce or so the other
day finally move won some games we made
the Elite Eight last year we good but
finally the other day I get there I
forgot the sauce the same thing and I
was like hey can I get that extra and
I'm reaching my pocket like coach it's
on the house Wow 30 30 cent you know
what if you arrived if you win Monday
night you'll never run out of salsa I'm
not there's no way I'll ever get like
the burrito complem a bi work on that
we'll work on that
Congrats thank you you know because as I
said it's a long road and there are a
lot of people involved in it and there
are casualties along the way and you
know you hope that you're a good dad to
your daughter and you know those kind of
things but you're here with a team that
shouldn't be a surprise to people that
I'm sure it is because they forget what
happened last year when he lost to I
believe Villanova so good luck this
weekend and just so you know if you do
beat Michigan State you ruin my bracket
I hope that happens okay
all right I'm fine with that yeah he's
Chris beard the head coach at Texas Tech
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]